- We're being dramatic.
- Are we?
(classical music)
- John can you bring out the first course?
- Who's John?
- Wow!
(screams)
- Okay John!
- Alfred is here.
- [Man] John what you got?
- Oh!
- These are queen leaf cutter ants.
They're found in Colombia,
Venezuela and Brasil.
- Okay South America, ya'll eating bugs.
The (beep).
- Alfred you're fired.
- They smell like they're roasted.
- They're not going to smell like anything
- Well you don't know, they might be.
They smell roasted.
- I've had worse in my mouth.
- Aaah!
- They're like a little coffee bean.
- It tastes like a bug.
It tastes like what it looks like.
- It had like a filling.
- Ugh! No, mine didn't!
- You know what?
It doesn't taste bad.
- It tastes like bitter chocolate.
- So when I took the first bite
it did taste like Corn Nuts.
I was like, you know what?
I'll probably get used to it
- I like that it was small.
Like if I was trying to
get in the mood quick
I would pop one in.
- I think I'd eat it again.
- The fact that it's not here anymore.
(classical music)
- Didn't I fire you?
- [John] It's called Balut.
- Oh no!
- [John] It's a delicacy
from the Philippines.
- There's a baby bird in here.
- Good night.
I'm not even trying it.
- Alfred, what the (beep) are you doing?
- There's juice.
(man slurping)
- Oh, it tastes like an egg.
(beep) like a duck.
Literally.
- It doesn't taste bad.
(screams loudly)
- It got on my velour.
- Oh my God, that was a big bite!
- It honestly tastes like an egg.
Like I get it.
I'm like oh yeah, it's an egg.
- For me, it tasted like chicken
but it's just the look of it.
- It looks way worse than it tastes.
(classical music)
- This dish is from Jamaica
- (beep) you.
- [John] Cow Cod soup.
And these are bull penises.
(screaming loudly)
- He left that part 'til the end.
You were like, oh yeah...
And then, eat this dick.
- It's like which part
of the dick do I want?
Normally I don't get a choice.
- It smells good.
- Listen, I'm not going to
lie this smells delicious.
- I don't think I can take all this dick.
(man laughs)
(screams loudly)
- Why does this keep happening to me?
- Oh! Oh, it's spicy.
- John is just laughing
John you think this shit is funny?
- Oh! Not bad?
- That's some good dick.
- Yeah. It's not bad.
It's very chewy.
(screams)
- We have a soup in Dominican
Republic called Sancocho
and it's basically
something just like this.
- This is like a Menudo situation.
Menudo is a Mexican soup.
- I'm going to go home
and tell my boyfriend
yo I had dick today.
He's going to be like Julisa,
You didn't have my dick
so what were you doing?
(classical music)
- Oh I know this one.
Durian!
- [John] And it's from Southeast Asia.
- That odor is strong.
- For some people it smells really bad
but to me that smells really sweet.
- It's like fermenting fruit.
- And that's why it gets you horny
- Because you're drunk.
- [Man] It's very like fleshy
- No?
- I don't think it's bad.
- I don't know.
It was like slimy.
- The texture is a little weird
but it give me mango vibes.
- See I think my tastebuds are different
because it tastes good to me.
- Out of anything
I do feel like this will get me horny too.
- On the contrary.
- I don't think Imma have sex for a month.
- I feel like if people have
to do this to get in the mood
I'm all for it.
I just don't think this works for me.
- I'm just gon' stick
to drinking and (beep).
- [Woman] John, get outta here.
Go back to your wife and kids.
You don't need to be doing this.
You're better than this.
- [Man] Seriously.
(classical music)